uh
welcome to our fourth problem session
uh we're going to be talking about
binary trees mostly today we'll talk a
little bit about
binary heaps which is a topic we won't
cover until
next tuesday but it will appear
in a very small ways on your problem set
four which will be due next friday
so i'm going to go over a little bit of
that material today
but it's mostly concern the the subject
material for today is mostly
uh binary trees specifically
being applied to set data structures and
sequence data structures
as uh professor domain talked to you
earlier this week um but
for now uh actually as of yesterday
you've seen all of the data structures
that we're going to cover
to imp that that will implement the set
interface and the sequence interface
right those uh those nice tables that
uh professor domain has been showing you
right
uh those are now complete right we have
uh some data structures that are really
good constant time
operations for some operations so we
might choose them for some
uh applications and this week
we've been describing to you trees which
achieve like really pretty good for any
type of query operation on my
sets or sequences pretty good meaning
logarithmic time not quite constant
but for our purposes log n is
i mean on your computer practically
right not asymptotically but practically
log n is going to be at most what
on your computer
something like 64 right
any input that you're operating on with
uh and machine words as your input right
uh you need to be able to address all
those machine words right
in in your input and on your computer
the size of your machine word addresses
is 64 bits
right and we assume that the word size
is at least log
in the num the size of your input so
that you can address the input
right right so for your purposes on your
computer
log n is going to be no more than 64
which means you get a maybe a 50 times
overhead or you know for smaller
instances it could be more like 10 right
if you've got like
a thousand things that you're working on
right it's not that bad
right it's a constant it's not a
constant factor for theory purposes
but for your purposes log n is much
better than a than a polynomial factor
right another factor of n okay so
uh you've seen all the code
you've seen implementations of all of
these set and sequence interfaces right
so i went ahead and wrote a little i
compiled all of that code from your
recitation notes of all of the different
interface implementations and what i did
was i
wrote a little test program to see how
they ran
on a real machine right so i have a
little
test code here um right so i have a
little folder
that lists you know an array
implementing a sequence a binary tree
implementing a sequence a dynamic array
implementing
all these kinds of things right then set
things a sorted array being a set
and a binary tree and a hash table right
these are our implementations i'm not
using
python dictionaries for hash tables i'm
using the implementations that are in
your
restation and i'm going to run this
little test efficiency
python code that basically is just gonna
for each one it's gonna do a bunch of
these different operations
and measure to see how much time it took
right i'm just logging how much time it
took it's not an asymptotic analysis but
you know hopefully we see some
separation yeah
so i'm going to press that it runs a
bunch of tests so let's take a look
uh okay so i got a bunch of sequence
operations right we got build set at get
at insert delete
at the various places right and i'm
giving these are the actual timings to
some scale
right to some resolution that i had for
these data structures
and you can see build actually build
on this machine just allocating some
array and clearing it is a really
efficient thing that's python's going to
do for me
and so that's actually it's miss
labeling that as log n right
uh but uh you know these other things
get out and set act
really really fast right that's constant
time and then these other things i
essentially have
can't do better than loop through the
thing and so it takes linear time
and again sequence uh stuff
setting at and getting at is slow but
deleting
and removing from the first thing i'm
just re-linking the pointer right
dynamic arrays again set at get ad is
fast because it's just
dynamic it's just regular arrays and
then
inserting and deleting last that's
getting the essentially constant time
now i'm actually when i'm running these
tests to deal with averages
i'm actually running these things a lot
of times and testing their performance
and so i'm not seeing the worst case
happen here
right i'm averaging over all of the
things which is exactly what
amortization
means and so that's why i'm getting good
performance here
uh a hash table again
really uh oh so this is what we talked
about
in problem session last week right
implementing a uh kind of a double-ended
queue with a hash table
uh this is that implementation i just
want to show it to you but it's actually
pretty good this is what javascript uses
for arrays
and then a binary sequence represents a
binary tree
right a balanced binary tree this is our
avl code that i had
and you know all the other things have
been really pretty bad at insert at and
delete at
but this one does comparable to all the
other things now you see these are a
little bit more
you know machine cycles than the other
things but
you know not so bad actually uh and then
on the set side of things
again we had a sorted array uh sorry
this is a set from
an array basically it's an unsorted
array i'm just looking for all the
things that's very bad times
sorted array does these fine operations
great but inserting deleting is
poor right that's why we need binary
trees
hash tables you know get good kind of
dictionary operations but really bad
order operations right
and then the binary search tree right a
set binary tree
uh again does quite good on all of these
things
in fact it's getting really quite good
it's getting better for some reason than
these the sorted array even did
so uh i don't know why
our implementations are not optimized at
all but it does pretty well
asymptotically yep um could you explain
again why the
in the first day of surgery was blog
this is just labeled based off the
timings right
it happens to be that probably there's a
c intrinsic underneath python
that allocates this thing and so it does
it really fast and so my
program that's looking at these numbers
and trying to guess what the asymptotic
running time is
these are just labels based on these
things ranges
i just it's it's mis characterizing
actually building it at any time
yeah well i mean in in actuality if it
was
c code right if all of this stuff was in
c
probably we'd see that that bar be
longer because it's actually having to
go through and touch all that memory
it's still doing that here but all the
python stuff is super crafty right it's
like
100 times slower than anything that c
does and so
you're seeing that that disparity here
does that make sense
okay so i just wanted to show you that
uh we might release this
for you to play around with but i just
wanted to
give you a taste of that okay any
questions
you move on how do i turn this off
up and off
shut down
[Music]
yes okay so what
all right so moving on to problems
working some problems uh so you have
your set of problems here uh the first
one is we're going to look at a sequence
avl tree right this is a sequence abl
tree how do i know that
you don't necessarily but these things
are certainly not
in sorted order of the things i'm
storied in them
right so it better not be a set avl tree
right is it an avl tree is it balanced
height balanced
yeah yeah basically actually if you take
compute the size of each subtree
right the left and right sub-trees on
all these you can confirm for yourself
are balanced right there they're
within plus or minus one of each other
actually this is about as far away from
balance as you could get
for this many nodes uh while still
maintaining hype balance maintaining avl
property
which is why this is an instructive
example it's kind of at the limit
okay and uh
what am i going to do this is a see
what's missing in this picture
if i'm claiming this is a sequence avl
tree
any ideas what's missing
what is the sequence avl tree store that
i'm not showing in this picture
what counts and
it's a sequence avl tree heights
right so it's a sequence avl trees
different than set available trees are
augmented by two things right because
i need to be maintaining balance during
rotations and so i need to store heights
i need to be able to tell what the
heights of these sub trees are in
constant time when i'm
walking up the tree fixing things and
the sequence
requires me to store their subtree the
numbers there
right so i don't know i'm not going to
draw it for all of these things but how
about for number 4
what's its height
one two three that's the longest path
from the sub the root subtree of that so
this is you know
height equals uh three that came from
height equals two and height is one let
everyone see that
yeah and then the size here how big is
that that's
one two three four five six seven right
so this is
i'm gonna put size equals seven
here right and that's coming from this
guy one two three
four and this guy
is two
right so how do i compute the subtree
size
it's my left subtree size plus my right
subtree size plus 1
right and my height is taking the max of
the 2 plus 1 right
all right so we did all that yesterday
so i'm
just labeling these things and what i'm
asking of you
is to perform a delete operation
is a sequence uh tree so i'm
i'm finding things by their index in the
tree right so i'm going to ask you to
delete the eighth thing
in my sequence okay so what is the
eighth thing in my sequence
yeah all right just to clarify is not
delete
a number correct well delete at
eight do you see that it's a sequence
operation
yeah so this is very important that you
differentiate between
sequence and set semantics right if i'm
dealing with the sequence
i better not be looking up intrinsic
things on this data structure right
because it's not an intrinsic data
structure it doesn't support that so if
i
wanted to support find
the say the index of key 8
or something like that right then all i
could do is it's similar to like an
array i would just have to loop through
the whole sequence and tell me if the
thing's in there
right can't really do better than linear
time this data structure is not designed
for that what is it designed for it's
designed to find things by their index
in the sequence right so uh
how do i find the eighth index
well i mean i'm looking at the tree and
i can just
you know count along the in order
traversal what's the inorder traversal
right zero one two
three four five six seven eight okay
found eight but what does a sequence avl
tree do
right it i'm storing subtree sizes
and when i'm here i don't know what
index i'm at right
how can i find out what index i'm at
from the root i look at my left sub tree
see how many it is
right there are seven things here
uh one two three four five seven
eight right yeah because i'm looking for
the ninth item
by index eight right so this is saying
that i'm the eighth item
right and the guy at index seven
does that make sense because i'm looking
at the subtree size here
so what do i know i know that the index
that i'm looking for is to my right
right so i go down over here
and i happen to know what am i what
index of
of am i looking for in this subtree
zero right i want the first thing in
this sub tree
my search index has changed now right
because i
essentially dealt with all of those
eight items
right so here i'm looking for the zero
thing in my index
i look to my left if i didn't have a
left sub tree i would be the zero thing
right and i would return me but there is
stuff in here so i'm looking for the
zero thing in here right
which is just him and i return it okay
and actually what i'm doing is i'm
deleting it
right so i delete it
yuck what's the problem here
i'm not high balance weird what's not
height balanced here
um the lug subtree is earth
so this guy's not height balance right
right
this guy's subtree is not height balance
right this guy's two this guy's one
okay so how do we fix it
we do some rotations right this is
actually the
bad case that with the third bad case
that we talked about yesterday
right if i tried to just left rotate
this
guy what would it look like it would put
12 here it would put 10 here and 8 would
be attached to that
now it's height balance wrong in the
other direction right that's no good
right so the way to handle this case
where
i'm badly skewed to the right
but my right subtree is badly skew is
skewed to the left
i have to do a rotation here right
rotation
and then do a rotation so that's that's
the formula okay
so here we first do a right rotation at
10
okay which gives me something that looks
like
8 10 okay
well obviously this is uh not better
than what was before but it's an
intermediate step so that we can fix it
right
we right rotate here and then we left
rotate here right
the default is that we would left rotate
here but because this had
the skew in the wrong direction i need
to
right rotate this one first and then we
can do it so now i
rotate all of these guys over right
and put 12 down here 8 here
10 here done
everyone see that that's what a rotation
looks like
okay it takes a little while to get your
mind wrapped around
what the transformation is but hopefully
you guys all followed
that transformation there was a little
magic while i was trying to draw yeah
i still don't feel like this tree is
high balance it's not
good observation why is that this thing
still has height three
what is the height of this thing one
right
this is height one and actually when i
was doing that rotation
i needed to update all these
augmentations right
how which augmentations did i really
need to which subtrees have changed
during those things
i don't remember what the thing looked
like what did the thing look like
10 10 had eight in its subtree
so its subtree definitely changed right
eight sub tree changed
twelve didn't change eventually
okay so there's the case analysis that's
in your lecture notes and was done in
recitation
right it tells you that these a b
c d kind of sub trees right
the ones that could change in these
things those sub trees don't change
the only sub trees that change during
one of these fixed operations when you
do one or two rotations
is either two nodes or three nodes that
whose subtree has changed here uh it
could have been the case that three
sub trees have changed right but in the
easy case
only two nodes x and y i think in the
notes
could have changed and so when i do that
i have to recompute
their augmentations from their
augmentations of their children
but uh it's only a constant number of
those so i just
recompute them because i the sub trees
below me haven't changed
right okay so we have a height mismatch
here
yeah should be where
eight is
right so uh originally in the picture
12 has a bunch of things in its subtree
right
10 and 8 and we just deleted seven right
so its subtree definitely changed there
used to be three
oh no sorry it did right yeah so here
three node sub trees have changed but
uh that's the actually the most i'm
showing you the worst
case right only three nodes possible in
doing one of these
double rotation things could have
changed their sub trees and so we just
have to
fix the augmentation of those three
things in the easy case it's just two
things
okay all right we have a uh on balance
how can we fix this
i could have been mean right i wanna be
able to
right rotate here right to rebalance i
could have been mean and switch these
two
right if i switch those two then i'd
have to do two rotations to fix this
thing because the middle one is heavier
than the
left one against what i'm doing right
but i'm not that mean so i'm going to
right rotate how do i do that well right
rotate
at 6 is going to bring all of this
down below 4 right and stick this
subtree
as the left child of 6. does that make
sense
yuck that's going to be fun to draw
i'm just going to redraw it that makes
more sense right
uh eleven three two
one and then six
five nine
eight twelve
ten that's the right rotation
at six is everyone cool with this
the rotation my x is 6 my y is 4
right i have a b c sub trees
right what i'm doing is kind of
switching
which of x and y is the root here right
so now y is the root
and b and c sub trees here now become
the children of x
underneath y and notice that hopefully
through all that process
my inorder traversal has not changed
we had to update our augmentations along
the way but you know it's a constant
every time we walk up the tree
and we walk up the tree only a
logarithmic number of times yeah
yes so every time we do a rotation we
just like
update the augmentation immediately
afterwards before we do any other
routine exactly
second part updating documentation just
means like
updating like the count and the height
just the properties and stuff yeah
basically what we did we
define when we augmented uh professor
domain yesterday
defined for you what a subtree property
is right
it meant a property that i can compute
only by looking at my children
the augmentations of my children
recursively right
so here uh instead of trying to
increment or try to think about locally
what this augmentation should be
i'm going to throw away my old
augmentation and just recompute it from
my children because
those recursively better be correct does
that make sense
yeah so just looking at how the rotation
works
so basically you're swapping four and
six so that way four becomes the parent
node
and six becomes the right note
i'm gonna draw this picture just
it's just something you gotta memorize
it's
this is x b
[Music]
c and a
can you see that picture okay
yeah it's in your notes it's not a big
deal right
but if you've got this structure where
x has a left child right
and these sub trees may be empty or not
doesn't really matter what i can do is i
can
move from here to there has the same
in-order traversal order
right but it's got a different shape and
in particular subtree
heights have changed which means it can
help us rebalance the tree
and that's that's the whole point of avl
does that make sense
and that's the right rotation this one
is this is a right rotation this is a
left rotation
any other questions
so as i'm walking up the tree every node
i might have to fix with the rebalance
but that rebalance does at most two
rotations
and there's at most log n ancestors that
i have
because my tree is height balance right
at 2 2 log n or something like that
right
which means that at max i might have to
do
four log n rotations right because each
one could
do two rotations so that makes sense now
in actuality you can prove that in a
delete operation
it's possible that you have to do a
logarithmic number of these rotations up
the tree
this was a that bad case this is called
the original tree i gave you is called a
fibonacci tree
it's the fewest it's the highest uh
height balanced tree you can have on a
on a given number of nodes
um uh that's it's
yeah the fewest nodes for a certain
height i i you can think of it either
way
and if you generalize that to a large
enough thing then that thing will take a
logarithmic number of rotations going up
now actually with an insertion you can
actually prove you can go through the
case analysis
uh an insertion operation will always
rebalance the tree after one
after one rebalance operation which
could include two rotations does that
make sense
yeah so in right rotation this guy
becomes a right child
yes
depending on whether you have a child
yeah so
if i didn't have a left subtree
can't perform rotation a right rotation
there
yeah so a right rotation necessitates
that i have a left child so if you're
doing it
and you'll see our code actually checks
to make sure you have a left child
right uh
that's that's a an assertion that you
might want to fire before you ever do
one of these rotations
anything else yeah so an insertion may
take
two rotations at most to fix a constant
number of rotations and the deletion
could take a logarithmic number of
partitions
now that's not something you need to
know it's not something i'm proving here
to you
uh just just something that's
interesting there are rebalancing
schemes like
in in clrs right they they introduce
a a red black tree to to introduce
balance
and that those trees actually have a
weaker bound on
it's not as is tightly height balanced
as as an
avl tree is it allows higher than skew
to right uh and because it's
kind of a weaker restriction they get
away with only doing a constant number
of rotations that
they can afford that before they fix the
tree
uh but you know a little more
complicated
very nice okay any questions on this
okay
so uh now so this is more of a
mechanical question
you'll get on your problem sets and now
we get more onto the uh
the theory type questions these are
going to be reduction type questions
uh okay so this first problem uh
thick nuri uh this is
anyone nick fury right so it's a
an avengers reference uh so basically
what happens in this thing he's got a
list of
superheroes uh that each have an opinion
on whether they should go fight santa's
okay
and uh their opinion
can be strongly positive or strongly
negative
and so what uh fick is trying to do is
find from among his
revengers uh what their
what the log n most extreme
opinion revengers are so that you can
talk to them right he doesn't want to
talk to everybody he wants to talk to a
you know logarithmic number of them okay
it's kind of
whatever all right so uh basically
we have a uh a classified situation
where you're given as a read-only input
data store
of these things in an array okay
and i want to find the log n
ones with the strongest opinions does
that make sense
and i want to do it and the first
problem is in linear time
okay so you actually don't know how to
do this yet
you'll know how to do it with material
that you cover
in uh well they teach you one way to do
it in o46 but we're not going to get you
there right now uh we'll teach you
another way to do it
uh in uh on tuesday
right which is via binary heaps okay
binary heaps are an interesting thing
that implements a subset
of the set interface okay
really it just you can build
on some iterable x okay i
collect a bunch of things these items
have keys right it's a key
data structure in the same way it's
implementing what we call a priority
queue interface i can build these things
i can insert things
but i'm not going to do that here all i
really need here for this
situation is a delete superlative kind
of operation in this case
probably max delete
max
okay so this is like a i got a data
structure
right i'm calling these things does that
make sense yeah that's a priority
yes a priority queue is essentially
something that implements these two
things
actually there's a third one where i can
insert a new thing right but i'm not
going to need that right now
so that's what a priority queue is and
actually a set this is a subset of the
set
interface right right the nice thing
about
a heap which i won't show you how it's
done
right but what a heap can do so
if i had both of these operations
implemented using a
set avl tree how long would these things
take me
how long does it take to build a set avl
tree
and log in right because essentially i'm
getting a sorted order out of this thing
right if i'm inserting these things one
at a time right
or i could sort them and then put them
in a tree in linear time like you saw
a couple days ago right in recitation
but i have to sort them at some point
right i'm kind of
i need to take at least n log n time
because
if i'm going to be able to return their
order their traversal order in linear
time
and i have this lower bound of m log n
on sorting i kind of needed to spend and
log in
time here right and how long would this
delete max take
i started so long log in right so it's a
set avl tree
where is my max it's the rightmost thing
i can just walk down the thing
take it off maybe i have to rebalance
but you know that's a login
operation right it's the same as like
insert last in my substrate
right so for a set avl tree
this is n log n this is uh log n
right now
there's another data structure that does
better for one of these operations and
the same for the other one
that we've learned earlier
anyone remember said avl tree didn't
actually give us anything over
a sorted array in a dynamic
array okay so what that did right
was we have a we could sort it in n log
n time using merge sort or something
like that
and then we could just pop off the last
one end times right
that would be an amortize i mean if i
didn't care about
taking up that size i could do it in
worse case constant time i just read off
the first
the last one i don't need to resize the
array ever right i can just
ignore that does that make sense okay
but that's okay if i had a data
structure
that implemented these two operations
can someone tell me a
uh an algorithm to generate
fixed list don't worry about running
time right now but that just uses these
two operations
yeah um so we built the data structure
it's ordered from least to greatest for
absolute value
so don't don't don't worry about uh
where things are ordered or anything
like that i don't tell you how these
things
are implemented right all i'm saying is
i can
i can accept a bunch of these things and
i can
remove the maximum and return it
okay yeah anyways just build it but make
sure that you build it such that the
opinion levels are the absolute value of
the opinion levels sure okay
so that's that's a nice thing what i'm
going to do as your colleague is saying
is i'm going to look through all of the
things in my input i'm going to
copy it over to some writable memory
store
okay right that read-only thing is not
relevant to this part of the problem
right what i'm going to do is uh
right sorry i'm thinking about your
problem set that we're writing
and mixing it up okay so uh we copy it
over
to uh our new uh like linear size
array right and but instead of putting
their values there i'm going to put the
absolute values of their values that
make sense i just check if it's negative
it is i put the positive thing there
right okay and then and then i
stick that array in this build right i
put that
there right so that'll take some
whatever this build time is and then i
can
delete max k times or i can delete max
some number of times however many things
that i need
right that the if i if i want log n
highest things i can just
do that log n times right so for this
if i had such a data structure i could
do this in one run of this operation
and log in runs of this operation does
that make sense i can solve this problem
reducing to this data structure right
now for a sorted array or a
sat avl tree right this operation kind
of kills me already
takes m log in time right the nice thing
about a binary heap
is it does this operation in linear time
you will see that on tuesday and it does
this operation
in login time
okay so how what's the running time
if i use a heap to binary heap to
implement this data structure
order of n times order log n
times log n how big is log n squared
log squared n compared to n
is smaller right so if i add those two
running times together it's still linear
right
okay so that's how you solve the first
problem okay
i didn't have to tell you what a binary
heap was or how it did what it did all i
needed to tell you was that it did this
operation in linear time
and it did this operation login type
okay
yeah all right the magic will be shown
to you on tuesday
part b says now suppose fixed computer
is only allowed to write to at most log
and space
well okay that's a problem here right
because we before we copied over
the entire array filtered it out right
and then did some operations but we
couldn't even afford this if we couldn't
store the whole thing
externally in writable memory right
okay so we can't do that so in some
sense this is a more restrictive
environment
right i can do less things
than i could it's a uh it's less
powerful than my previous situation
where i had as much space as i wanted to
use right
so it kind of makes sense that
i maybe couldn't get
the running time bad that bound that we
had before right
maybe i have to sacrifice something
because i'm in a more restrictive
computational setting right okay
now this is something you could solve
with binary heaps but you don't have to
you could solve it
with uh scent adl trees
as anyone have an idea of how you could
solve this using a set avl tree
i'm limited by my number of mice my
my space is at most log n
yeah all right so how much space does
this indial tree take
right space right there's constant
number of pointers for each one of these
nodes
right and i'm storing in nodes and space
right basically every data structure
we've shown you
takes space the order of the things that
we're storing
right it's not using additional space it
might take
more time to do certain things but the
space is
you know takes the number of items we're
storing plus
maybe a constant factor right
right so i'm going to draw my input here
which i can only read i can't write
do i give it i'm just going to call it a
okay so this is my list
of all the revenger opinions okay i can
only read it
but my computer can only write to this
logarithmic amount of space
what can i put in that space
well i can i can certainly put log n
things in there okay
so if i'm given that restriction i
probably want to build a data structure
of that size
right you know containing that number of
things that make sense
because what else are you gonna do right
okay so i i gave you an idea maybe we
could use a set avl here
right i see a logarithm in my answer
right it's very possible that we might
have
you know sorted arrays right or set avl
things those
those things give me a log somewhere in
my running times right
so kind of makes sense that i might have
maybe a set avl tree here why why why
would a set avl tree be helpful for me
yeah because it started and you know you
have the direct russell order you can
calculate the traversal order
and insert like anxiety sure i can do
all those things but in particular
it's going to help me be able to find
a large one quickly right if i if i
kind of uh have a set of things it's
going to be
and i and i'm maintaining this data
structure by adding things incrementally
to it
right i can find out what the biggest
one is
or the smallest one pretty fast right
and log in time
right so if i have log n things in a
in a tree here right what's the height
of that thing
log log n that looks familiar so what
can i afford i can afford
a linear number of op set avl tree
operations on this data structure right
okay you had a question okay i'm sorry
yeah um for there'll be an
avl tree does it have to be a bts tree
it's
uh bts bst
right so when i talk about uh someone
likes korean k-pop
okay uh so uh
bst but in natural kind of in
the lingo that you're probably used to
hearing in other contexts
what we mean in this class is a set adl
tree right
now sometimes what people
refer to as a binary search tree doesn't
have balance
semantics right so we might call in this
class a set binary tree
right but really
they're useful because they're balanced
so we're going to usually just assume
that we're
talking about balance things here now a
set avl tree has these binary search
tree semantics
where the keys are ordered these items
have keys and they're ordered it's a set
interface right
whereas we also presented to a sequence
interface
right for which these these things don't
even have keys how could i
store set semantics there right so but
that's the distinction that we mean when
we say
uh binary search tree versus
really a set avl tree versus yeah so if
we're going to make an avl tree out of
this would that mean that like
we when we make a node we tell it like
we are keying on the absolute value
okay so when you're uh
making a set to avl tree you got to tell
us what
if you're storing objects you got to
tell me what their key is right if
you're just storing some numbers
like what i'm doing here right now this
isn't a set avl tree right but if i'm
just storing numbers
i have to tell you the items that i'm
storing are the keys
okay and then everything follows right
but if you've got an object that you're
trying to sort like
the students in this room you got a lot
of properties
right i want to all the uh
the people with phone number right
maybe i want to key you on phone number
for some reason that's going to help me
find out where you live i don't know
this is getting i don't want to go there
okay
so but if i if i give you a set to avl
tree
i got to tell you what it's keyed on if
i give you a sequence avl tree
right it's obvious what my traversal
order is going to be because i'm giving
you a sequence
right that's what the input gate was
right
does that make sense all right so i've
got this
set avl tree of size log n
what should it be keyed by
absolute value of their preference right
or of their
opinion i don't remember what this is
called so
but i what log n things do i put in here
i don't know i i don't know anything
about these things
what makes one better than another right
let's just put the first log in things
that make sense
all right what could that
tell me now i've put this thing in it
how long did that take
log n times log log n
time right but that's much less than our
running time right so
that we're looking for so i don't really
care right
i mean i want you to say how long it
took
but for my purposes i know that it's
lower than the running time i'm looking
for
so and i did that operation once i don't
really care about it anymore
okay yep how did you get log n because
the number of things i'm storing in this
thing is log n
and so if i pattern match
the build time of an avl tree and i
stick log n in there
right then it's log n times log log n
gotcha okay so is that for one iteration
well right now i've just built this
thing right
maybe i uh well i just built it once
uh i'm asserting too that maybe i don't
need to build it again
right what could i do instead so right
now
i know i haven't filtered my data at all
right i'm just storing these things in
sorted order in some way
right what can i do
to maybe start processing the rest of
the data
yeah well i didn't like try to scroll
through
the list a and try to like remind
someone that's bigger than
like try to keep the maximum ah
kind of sweep this guy over inserting
things
and always maintaining you know if i do
that and i keep sticking things in
i'll have this sorted thing at the end
and now i can just read off the
biggest k things right however
as i'm inserting things across here
my thing's growing i'll just delete this
oh delete small is fun
i like that idea right basically yeah
basically replace it right so
what i'm going to do here's a proposal
we're going to take the next guy stick
it in
awesome which one don't i care about now
the smallest one there so kick the
smallest one out
now this one that i stuck in may be the
smallest
right so i just kind of passed it
through this thing but how long did that
take me
it took me the height of this tree
what's the height of the tree log log n
right so i put one in
i pop one out that's the smallest right
and i keep doing that all the way down
the thing how long did that take
yeah i'm processing n minus log n
things which is basically n right
and each one of those operations took me
height of the tree time
so that gives me the running time that
we're looking for
and log log
yeah it's like recognition of like a
slide yeah it's a kind of a sliding
window technique you may have
been using one recently
okay everyone okay with this yeah let me
just
remember the context that we're talking
about is log
log n like tree and like what where so
this thing
the size of this thing is log log n yeah
i mean sorry
log n and the height of this thing is
log of
the size
in relation to like our little like
login size
like right there sticking this full of
small log log entries or like like no so
sorry
i'm taking this stuff there's no
intermediate data structure here
i'm just sticking all these things into
a via
bsta i mean a set abl yep
into one set avl right of size log n
i'm sticking a guy in popping the
worst guy out right going through all
the things
i need to make sure when i'm sticking it
in i'm
you know keeping track of which revenger
it is and that i'm taking the absolute
value and all those
you know nitty-gritty kind of things but
that's the basic idea right
i'm just taking this i'm sliding the
window in
putting something in taking something
out that may or may not probably is not
the
same thing and at the end of this
procedure
right the invariant i'm i'm maintaining
here is that my thing
always has the k largest opinions
of the ones that i've processed so far
right that's obviously true at the
beginning when i build this thing
and when i get to the end i've processed
all the things
so and this has size log n and so
i have the log n largest
like highest extremist opinions
and then i can just do an inorder
traversal of this thing and read
and return does that make sense and i've
only used
logarithmic space
okay yeah so i don't get it are all the
opinions in that uh
are all the opinions in that avl tree
all of these opinions are in the abl
tree
and at ever at some point
i will insert every
opinion into this abl tree but i'll
be removing the ones that i don't care
about as i go
does that make sense i'm always
maintaining the
the invariant that this thing before i
insert something
has exactly log n items in it and then
i'm maintaining that invariant
by sticking one in taking one out oh
okay so then which one are you
always the min right because i'm wanting
the the largest ones
and the mid by absolute value but yeah
so i'm keying by the absolute value of
these opinions
total run time here right it's
bookkeeping right
so it took me
a log n times log
log and time to build this data
structure at the beginning
right plus n times
log log n
i did you know basically n operation
asymptotically and
operations this way it's actually n
minus log n
operations right and each one of those
operations tree operations
you know doing one insert one delete
each one of those
took the height of the tree time and so
this is that good
yeah if instead of blind we just insert
and do we
do a comparison and then so the in
inserting and deleting
uh a set avl tree is actually doing
comparisons within its data structure
just compare with the name sure you
could do that
right right so you could i could do it
the other way right
i could remove the smallest element here
to start with
right and then i compare it with this
guy
and then whichever is bigger i stick it
back in
same thing right it's just am i doing
the delete first and then
then the insertion or i'm doing the
insertion first and then the deletion
any other questions lots of questions
all right well i'm probably gonna have
to skip the problem
uh we're gonna move on to uh c
s so now s c l r
all right what's the reference here
yeah clrs right so these are four
academics who wrote a popular textbook
in computer science
uh okay this is the same kind of k kind
of thing okay
they found k first editions and they
want to auction them off
uh people can go on to their website
they have a bitter id
it's a unique identifier right and they
can place a bid
for one of these books right and
they can change it during the bidding
period but
you know at the end of the bidding
period the
academics want to know who the uh
you know what is the expected revenue
i'll get by selling to the k highest
bidders does that make sense
yeah okay so
note that before i
build this data structure i know what k
is k is a fixed thing
right right because my my running time
of this get revenue
depends on this k it's not an input to
that operation
right so k is kind of i don't know what
it is
a priori it could be n over 2 it could
be log n
right it could be 1
right but the data structure i build
needs to satisfy these running time
properties no matter what choice okay
that the academics told me does that
make sense
okay so what i need to do is
as as time is going on people are
placing new bids and updating their bids
right
and you know those updates can take
longer time
but as soon as i close the window i want
to be able to tell in constant time
right
what the k highest bidders are
any ideas on how to do this what are the
operations that i have to do i have to
be able to place a new bid right i
associated with a bidder is an id
and a bid which is also an integer right
how many dollars i'm going to pay for
this book
uh update the bid in some sense i need
to find
whether that person placed the bid
before right
in my data structure so at some point
i'm going to need a find on bidder id
does that seem possible right so i might
want to have some kind of dictionary
on bitter ids right when i say that i
want to
have a dictionary on something right i'm
not specifying to you yet
how i'm going to implement that
dictionary right what are my usual
options
a hash table but what if i need worst
case time
a set avl tree right that's going to be
your go to for a dictionary
right because that's going to give me
log n time to find things by a key
right it's the only thing except for
assorted or
sorted you could also use a sorted array
right but that's going to
not be dynamic and here we're updating
who's in my data structure all the time
right
people are going in and placing bids
right new
new people placing bids so my set of
things that i care about is changing all
the time
so that's probably going to steer me
away from sorted arrays because
they're not good with dynamic operations
okay so i'm going to need some kind of
dictionary on
bitter ids but i'm also going to need to
maintain the the sum
right of the k highest bidders does that
make sense
right and so in some sense i need to
keep track of
an ordered notion of
the bidders right the bids that are in
my data structure does that make sense
right so order is going to be important
on the bids i'm going to need to look up
on bitter id
and that's about it right
okay yeah just checking so something
yes correct yeah so uh
that's a very good observation right if
it runs in worst case
time it also runs unexpected that time
right because there's essentially no
randomization that i'm talking about
here right
yeah it's so there's a stronger notion
which we want you to specify
which that actually there is no
randomization here we're not using a
hash table
right in this class that really that's
the only situation where
uh that's going to be an issue right uh
so
uh but if it is uh what this problem is
saying
uh for each other state whether your
running time is worst case expected
and or amortized what we're really
trying to get you to say is
what's the uh
evaluate the running time of your
algorithm with the proper qualifications
right
if it took worst case i want you to say
that it took worst case
if it took if you use the hash table i
want you to say expected
and if these operations i were sometimes
really bad
but on average they're really good if i
did a lot of them that's that's
amortized right
right or if i reduce to using a dynamic
array
right or if i reduce to using a hash
table those dynamic operations would
still be amortized right
okay so the dynamic ones uh nice thing
about
linked data structures is that dynamic
operations aren't amortized right
so we're gonna get be able to get now
for this problem we can actually get
worst case bounds so we're going to try
for that
you can also do it in expected using
some hash tables for that
that dictionary right okay so
when you approach a data structures
problem in this class
you want to tell me what it is you're
storing
first off right tell me
what's supposed to be in those things
right some invariants on this data
structure
to you know make sure that when i do
queries later
right that these things are being
maintained right so that
uh you know if i have you know if i'm
maintaining a sorted array
right and i'm supporting an operation to
find the maximum
i better anything i do to this data
structure better be maintaining the
invariance that these things are in
sorted order and the last thing
has the maximum item because my max
return thing is going to look there and
return that
does that make sense so i want to tell
you you want to tell me what is being
stored
at you know a generic point in time
during your data structure
right what is being maintained so that
when i support a dynamic operation or a
query
right in a dynamic operation where i'm
inserting and deleting things from this
thing
i need to make sure that i'm maintaining
those invariants
and when i'm querying i can actually
rely on those invariants
to to answer my query does that make
sense
okay so for this problem this is
okay uh any ideas
i have two two kind of keys that i might
have to deal with one's a bid id and
one's a
a bid right so how could i
if i have two keys right that i might
want to
maybe order on one and look up on
another
how many data structures do you think
i'm going to use
two that's a pretty good guess okay
so one of them let's just guess right
like i need to be able to look up on
bid right so let's
store these bitters
right in some kind of dictionary that's
going to be able to look up those things
fast right so
you know two data structures right one
is a
a dictionary on
a keyed
on bitter
id okay
what else am i going to want
what's up
the other way around a dictionary stored
on the bids
is a dictionary what i want here
i want to maintain order somehow right
because i want to maintain the k
biggest things that i've seen so far
right now
if if i had at some point in time right
what's going to happen right if i'm
maintaining the k largest at any point
in time
it's possible that one of those bidders
maybe decreases his bid
right so it's no longer in the highest
i'm going to also need to keep track of
the other guys to see who i should add
back into that set
for example right so here's an idea
i'm going to keep not just one other
data structure but
two other data structures maybe this is
a leap
you don't have to do this there's a way
to do it with just one another
but i'm going to store two more one is a
kind of a data structure
to store
with uh store
the k highest
bidders
and a data structure to store the
n minus k highest bidders
does that make sense
so this separates my problem quite
nicely right
if every time someone does an
interaction with this data structure
right
i can check to see whether it's bigger
than the smallest thing in here
right if it is i can do the same kind of
trick i did before right
i can remove it and stick my new one in
there
right and where do i but i removed it i
have to maintain this
property right so i stick it in here
right
there's another case what's the other
case
it's smaller right in which case
i don't do anything to this data
structure and i just stick it into here
that makes sense right so what are the
operations these data structures need to
maintain finding the minimum or the
maximum
of these two sets does that make sense
and actually not
really the where are those operations i
don't have them anymore
but they were the priority queue
operations they had
uh delete max right and also insert
where things that it did well on right
so any priority queue right anything
that
can deal with maxes and mins right
is good right and and what what's a data
structure you know that can deal with
maxes and mins pretty efficiently
the set avl right so
instead of data structure here i'm going
to say
set avm
and obviously it's going to
be keyed by
bid right because that's the thing that
i'm going to want to find max's and mins
over
okay everyone following the logic here
of why i mean
i'm maintaining these things so this is
this is the level of an invariance that
i want to maintain because
when i go to for example do this query
get revenue right i can just run through
and
sum all of these things oh wait how much
time do i have
do i have k time no i don't have k time
so i don't
i can't afford to sum up all of these
things at the end of my
right i have to i have to return it to
you in constant time
any ideas yeah just
compute you know update a song right
along with this
data structure i'm going to keep a
fourth thing
which is just total
of their bits right i'm going to call it
like a
t okay
and that's something i'm maintaining
it's part of my data structure
right it's you could think of it as i'm
augmenting this thing with a number
right and the point of augmenting this
thing with the number
right is that i can just if i need to
know what the total of this stuff is i
can just look at that number
does that make sense all right
so now i think you know we're almost
done we're basically done
right how do we do this uh
someone walk through to me how i would
get revenue with this data structure
i just i basically kind of told you look
at this number
return it right because that's the
invariance that i've maintained
on my data structure i'm relying on this
invariant now
i better make sure this is good when i
do dynamic operations
right i make sure i maintain it but if i
by induction
are ensured that all of this stuff is
good and when i do a dynamic operation
all that stuff is maintained
then i'm all good right so get revenue
after i kind of did all this extra work
right it's very easy i just look at this
number and return it
okay so when we're grading a data
structures problem usually we give you
some points first for
setting up your data structure
separately from the operations and then
we give you
points per operation that you
successfully deal with
and then some points for correctness and
running time
yeah you have a question so
would total be like a thing that we
update whenever we
um like mess around with the highest
bitter tree and then
and minus k highest bigger tree sorry
say that again
so like are we treating like the total
like of like an augmentation that we
update every time we do something yeah
yeah
so it's just a one number it's not
really a data structure it's just one
number
that i'm storing with my my database
right
okay all right so how do i implement
a uh new bid operation
yeah can we assume that the bids will
also be unique
can you assume that the bids may be
unique no
right so that's actually something that
is a really useful observation
we've been talking about set data
structures
as requiring unique keys right
how can i deal with non-unique keys it
actually turns out that you know hash
table it's really important that these
be
unique keys right because i i need to
check whether it's in there i'm looking
for that
single key and when i find it i have to
return right if i had multiple things
with that key
i might not return the one that i'm
looking for right it doesn't even make
sense
right but you can generalize the
set uh
uh kind of infrastructure right
to deal with multi-sets how can i how
can i do that
well with each key right
again i'm storing unique keys with each
key i can link it to a sequence data
structure
or any other data structure right and
what i'm do is i'm going to
anything that has that key i'm going to
stick it in that data structure
right so instead of storing one item
there i have the possibility of storing
many things there
now i have to change the semantics here
right if i'm saying find on this key
well now i could say i'm going to return
all of the things with that key
or i'm going to show our some thing with
that key
right but you get the idea all i have to
do is map it to
some other data structure to maintain
those things like maybe
i want all the things with that key
i want to find the one with this other
key right
so maybe i link to a set data structure
that can search on other things right
but the idea here is we maintain this
uniqueness key property
right i have to relax my semantics so
that i'm storing
multiple things at that key location
does that make sense
yeah why does it matter whether you've
said the entree
or not uh it does uh so
it's going to matter here right because
i have bids
right and the bids could be non-unique
right
two people could have the same you know
uh bid and by our definition of a set
data structure it had to have unique
keys so if i stuck in all these things
keyed by bidder you got a problem right
now in actuality we can get away with
that by storing basically a
linked list of all the things with that
key and we'd be fine
right and then whenever i want to
return one i could just do but actually
a binary tree
right actually is flexible enough that
in most implementations you can just
store a bunch of those things but
actually our run times
do worse then right what does it mean to
find next in my sequence
right what does it mean to find the
to return the next larger thing above
this key
doesn't really make sense because there
could be multiple ones which one do i
return
and if i repeatedly do find next on this
data structure
right i might not loop through all the
things
right so some stuff breaks down
in our interface right so i would
prefer you use unique keys in this this
kind of situation
next tuesday i think with binary heaps
uh we'll deal with
non-unique keys that's fine but
if you're gonna use non-unique keys in
here
you just gotta be a little bit careful
about the semantics
okay yep
uh so you get the same uh
running time you the you have to change
the semantics on what you mean by find
something
right i just want to return anything
with this key
right what if everything has the same
key then it takes constant time
i just returned the first thing
it's i mean these are special cases that
you know you have to think about right
uh i don't like thinking about them
right so i just like
having unique keys and if i want a
situation where i have non-unique keys
i'm going to basically put collisions at
that key
into a new data structure right it's
just easier for me to separate out my
head
on what's happening because all of the
running times that we proposed
you know very strong definitions for
unique key
you know when you're dealing with a
multi-set it's a little bit more
problematic
any other questions i we really need to
kind of move on here
right uh dictionary ketone bitter
we still haven't implemented any dynamic
operations
new bid what do i do uh
what am i going to need for my update
i'm going to be able to
need to essentially find in each of
these data structures
where that bidder is right
and if i just have a thing keyed on
their bid
right the interface doesn't tell me what
their old bid was
it just tells me what their bidder id is
right so if i just had their bidder id
and their new bid how the heck am i
going to find out
which of these dash or where in these
data structures they are
right what i can do is i can store
in this dictionary which i can look up
in some amount of time right a pointer
to where it exists in these things
does that make sense this is called
cross linking you may have
done that a little bit in problem set
two or something like that
yeah are we storing a pointer to a
specific figure
yeah exactly right so the the invariant
we have is that all of the bidders we've
processed so far exist in these data
structures
right in one of these data structures
and because we've used a set avl tree
right
in particular exists in a node of one of
these data structures
right what we can do is in this thing
maintain pointers right
mapping each of the bitter ids to their
location in these data structures
and why is that going to be a useful
thing
right uh say i mapped this dictionary
right
what could i use for this dictionary to
get the running time we're looking for
i could use a hash table or a set avl
right if it's set avl
i'm going to get logarithmic time worst
case
with a hash table i'm going to get
constant time but it's expected right so
it could be linear time in the worst
case
right so we're going to use a set avl
tree right because that's what we do
right now and that's going to give us
worst case
okay so what i'm going to do is for each
one of these things i'm going to store
that pointer so what i'm going to do
is first i'm going to do that operation
we had
if i'm adding a new bitter right i'm
going to take
the you know the d and b right
these two values that object that's
that that bitter object or whatever i'm
going to look at the smallest thing in
this
data structure right see if it's bid
is bigger than my
my the the thing i'm inserting right if
it is then i'm not going to touch this
data structure i'm just going to insert
it in here
and now after i insert it in here i know
exactly where it is in the data
structure i just inserted it
right right so now
holding that in my hand the node right
i can go and insert that bitter into
here right
by bit id right so it's going to take
logarithmic time
and now i can store with that node
my pointer to this data structure does
that make sense
and in the other case i kind of do the
same thing right
if it's bigger than the smallest thing
here i pop that smaller thing out stick
it in there
and i stick my new guy in here
cross-linking
each of those pointers along the way
does that make sense hopefully
kind of kind of okay yeah
and for update very similar right if i
want to update
a certain bidder i look in this data
structure
finds the bidder
traverse that pointer to wherever it is
in one of these avl trees
right if it's in this if it's in this
one
i just remove it from the tree right or
i remove it from the tree and then i
reinsert
right with whatever the new bit is right
and if it's in this one again i remove
it from the tree
reinsert and whichever these things is
and then i might have to you know swap a
constant number of things back and forth
here to maintain that this has the
k highest right and when i do those
dynamic operations
i'm always removing some constant number
of nodes in each of these trees and and
adding back in a constant number of
things and while i do that i just make
sure to update this total as i go
right his total was the sum of all of
the
bids in here and if i insert a new bid
in here
i have to add to that total and if i
remove one i have to remove from that
total but
again it's a constant number of things
i'm moving in and out of these data
structures
and so it can update this in constant
time that makes sense
now the look up here and the insertion
and deletion into here
those each took logarithmic time
worst case but i did a constant number
of them so
again longer than time does that make
sense that's
that's essentially this problem it's a
little
it's difficult right there's a lot of
moving parts here
right but if you just break it up into
describe to me and
like you really do a good job on this
part describe well
to me what your data structure has then
those descriptions of those algorithms
can be
pretty brief actually right so
you know in this one you tell me these
three data structures you tell me this
guy's mapping to its location and these
things
i'm maintaining this guy right and then
you just maintain those things with
dynamic operations and then use
those things for query operations that
make sense
okay
wow we have 10 more minutes
i'm going to briefly do four or four
okay
for you okay receiver roster we've got a
coach
she's got a bunch of football players
receivers
and wanting to start on our team
the uh some number of of players that
have the best
the highest performance okay and by
performance we mean
the average number of points they've
played in games that they have logged in
their system
right but actually their data is
incomplete
right they don't know which games and
how much they scored in all these things
there could be errors
right and so these interns they're up
they're constantly updating this
database with queries like
uh oh uh
you know never mind this person didn't
play in this game
or actually they did and they scored
this number of points
right that's the clear and record things
right and then at some point in time
right like when we start
when we want to play a game right i want
to be able to return
the the jersey with the k-th highest
performance and log in time
okay this is kind of a
kind of a rank query right right the kth
highest
okay uh now in actuality i might want to
return
all k highest players so that that might
be my
my roster right but this is you know a
more generalized query
it's more specific more it's it's
not really comparable but you get an
idea for why that might be useful to the
coach
i don't know maybe not okay so what's
the idea here
we have a lot of different things
floating around we got games
they have ids unique ids we got
receivers they have unique ids
and each receiver could play in many
games
right oh that's kind of worrisome
and many receivers could play in the
same game
these kind of many-to-one mappings are a
little confusing
and then we've got each player
receiver having a certain number of
points per game
and we're trying to sort them kind of by
their performance which is a rational
number
right which has to do with the number of
games they've played
and the total number of points right
now i see rational number i can't
compute that
right that's what we were talking about
last problem session right
but what i can do is i could store the
total number of games they played and
the total number of points they had
right and you could imagine by
augmentation similar to this
right every time i add a game
right one of these small operations i
can
update that information for each player
right
right if i'm just if one of these these
dynamic operations is affecting only one
receiver
i can you know update whatever it is in
in constant time probably right if i
just store with the player
what their total number of games is as
recorded by the database
and how many points they've scored then
if i have a data structure
that needs to sort
the receivers by their performance so i
might be able to find the kth one
right the k largest then
i can't compute that performance but
what can i do
i can compare two players based on their
performance using cross multiplication
right right because i have the numerator
and denominator of each of these
rationals and i can cross multiply
and figure out whether one's bigger or
smaller and as long as i have a
comparator
i can do set jbl stuff does that make
sense
okay so that's the i'm just going to
outline kind of the
the components of this data structure
okay well first off uh i'm gonna need to
record a receiver and a receiver could
have a lot of games
but the important this is kind of a
receiver centric kind of problem does
that make sense to you guys
right i'm not ever wanting to filter on
all the receivers playing a game
right i'm never like removing
i'm never removing a game from the
system i'm removing a
receiver from ever playing in a specific
game does that make sense
so if i'm storing a receiver and each
receiver has
some games associated with them kind of
makes sense i might want to have
a nested data structure right where
with maybe i have a a dictionary on
receivers
and for each one i store all the games
that they've played it
in some other data structure right with
each receiver
i store another its own data structure
containing all its games so that makes
sense
okay so that's the idea right we have
some kind of
i need to be able to look up receivers
right because uh you know i'm i'm
clearing them or i'm
recording them right so i'm gonna have a
you know
a dictionary or you know here i'm
looking for worst case login time
so i'm going to you know skip the
dictionary abstraction and go straight
for the set avl
avl uh
uh keyed
on receivers
i before c e except after c
it is i e i
okay that rule never works
okay uh set avl tree on receivers
and each one of those nodes right with
each one of those receivers
i'm going to store for each
[Music]
store a set
avl on games
okay why do i store a set avl on games
why don't i just store a list of all the
games
because if i want to remove this game
from a receiver i need to do that in
login time and
here what we're saying is that n is the
number of games
but the the number of receivers on the
team is always less than the number of
games so
right if i search in this avl tree
and i search in its avl tree i can
be assured that those two searches was
only login
yeah because i might i need to remove a
game right so
there you go then
what am i doing i'm returning the k
highest performance well i need for with
each one of these guys
i also store what was this augmentation
the sum of the points stored in these
games right
sum of points
and uh what was it
number games
because if i store both of those things
in constant time i'm going to be able to
compute
their performance right where i'm going
to be able to
you have the data i need to compare
performances yeah so you just don't
have variables yeah yeah it's just
numbers
right these aren't data structures this
is data structure these are just numbers
okay i'm storing that with each receiver
right but that's not going to help me
find the kth
highest player right none of these
things are sorted by performance right
so i need the last data structure
five
i need to store something dynamically
sorted by
performance so yeah
set avl storing
receivers
keyed on
performance now when i say keyed ketone
performance
you want to mention something about the
cross multiplication
right like i'm storing with each one of
these things this augmentation
and when i'm comparing two things i'm
using cross multiplication
but other than that then we can abstract
it away right you've
abstracted that function call and i can
imagine comparing two keys i can do this
right this is a theory thing i'm not
asking you to implement that
right but that's sufficient for me as a
reader of your solution
to be able to say yeah you know what
you're talking about
okay all right so how do i connect these
things
right the thing is i'm going to need to
be uh i need to update this
these things right when i
insert or remove a game right
so how do i know where these receivers
are
in this thing i store a pointer into
this data structure right
so up here i store a pointer
right to where it is in the data
structure right again i'm storing all
the receivers
this has the same size as the number one
data structure up there
has the same number of receivers right
but we're not quite done yet because i'm
not wanting to know
like who has the the best
performance right i want to know who has
the
kaith best performance ugh
how do i find the kate best thing in
this treat right i've got a tree
right set avl tree it's
mapped on performance right i know where
the last one is
but if i want to find the kate one from
the end how do i do that
it's an avl tree a set avl tree
all i'm storing is heights is there an
operation that you've
thought about you're not storing the
size of each
ah a set avl tree by default does not
store sizes right that's what a sequence
does
but you think maybe that would be
helpful in this situation
right yeah so actually if i decided to
augment by sizes also i could do the
exact same kind of sequence
find at operation right and i could be
able to look up
the n minus k item right
in here using the exact same function
for subtree at that i had
in the sequence avl tree stuff right so
actually in clrs they don't even bother
with sequence avl trees
right they go straight to if i wanted
this rank find functionality
on a sorted order of things right
then i could augment with subtree sizes
right
but it's actually a much more useful
general property
so we decided to present it to you in
the in the context of sequence abs juice
because then i can just
basically reduce to it when i get to
here okay so
that's kind of a structure of the data
structure that'll work on this problem
i leave it to you as an exercise to
implement all of these operations
for yourself or take a look at the
solutions the last one um
is going to be put online the solution
uh
it's pretty complicated it's what's
called you can think of the size
augmentation finding rank as a one-sided
range query
it's basically how many things are to
the right of this value
right what the last problem does is
walks you through a two-sided range
query
right where i want to know how many
nodes are between these two values
okay so it's a walk-through
all right thanks guys